It's showtime someone out there is trying to
kill us someone's always trying to kill us
richard sorry who is that now what now we go team
where are we zip-lining through
futuristic metallic tunnels too
don't hunt them to completion well i vote no
voting no debate it's not a democracy it's a rick
public when do i ask you for anything when do you
i haven't been to a full week of school in years
i don't know police a strange horny ocean man is
on my lawn sweetie don't get all worked up before
your job interview job interview yes is that so
hard to believe actually yeah something's off
all right what hide
how do we just hit buttons we're too big to fail
time to turn up the broiler
i think it's in our best interest to work as
a team yeah most people would call that family
okay it's okay morty that's what
you do let me deus ex machina
and let's go home say hello to my little me
new rick and morty starting
sunday june 20th at 11 p.m
this is out there even for us they
can hear you morty get ready for some fireworks
a little out of character to say this
right now but you guys look really cool
god why does everyone go cyberpunk birds that's
why you wanted to get out of town you think i'd
lie to you about why we're on vacation morty
i wouldn't lie to you well that's a lie huh
the door open the door rick is
it morty will you stop trying to
everybody attack one at a time is that the
best way to get up something awesome yes
what have we become why are we doing this
anymore because it's fun you little rat
morty this is gonna sound bad but
would you trust me not to kill you
new rick and morty starting
sunday june 20th at 11 p.m
oh my god come on let's go huh well i don't
nearly have the time to unpack this swim
and stream seasons one through four on hbo max now
Welcome back everyone this is going to be my
brand new rick and morty season 3 trailer video
we have brand new episodes coming this summer
i'll be doing videos for all of them so be sure
to subscribe to get all those i'll do a rick
and morty themed giveaway when the episodes
get ready to start airing it's actually going
to be overlapping with the marvel loki episodes
which i'm also doing videos for which is funny
because the show runner on marvel's loki series
actually came from rick and morty and a lot of
marvel's loki series is trading on rick and morty
tropes like it's loki going against a bunch of
alternate versions of himself they even have a
version of the citadel of rix on the loki series
which is called the time citadel they're in here
they're actually a lot of rick and morty people
that are now working on new marvel projects for
disney plus or marvel movies dan harmon himself
also consulted and helped him out with the first
dr strange movie so there is a lot of connection
between rick and morty and marvel but the other
really really good news is they confirmed
that they're going to drop all 10 episodes
this summer with no breaks they're not going to
do that weird thing where they release half the
season like in season 4 where you have to wait
six more months to get the rest of the episodes
in going forward year to year like rick and morty
season six season seven unless something really
terrible happens we'll get 10 new episodes without
any breaks every single year so i would expect to
get rick and morty season 6 episodes next year
they already said that they're actually working
on rick and morty season 7 right now but the
new trailer footage starts with that bc boys
sabotage track can't go wrong with the beastie
boys you could say it's apropos because rick
often sabotages himself more than he's one-upped
by anyone else and when you consider the citadel
of rix and all the alternate versions of ricks
from different dimensions he is metaphorically and
literally his own worst enemy next to evil morty
technically there is a funny easter egg for the
evil morty episode during this trailer that i'll
point out when we get to that part of the footage
but they revealed this scene that we've been
seeing all the other trailers as part of a larger
assault from the government in some big alien
attack that trying to arrest them and they have
anti-portal technology rick slaps himself and
activates some new plane inside his garage lab
it's kind of hard to tell what happens after
this because they jump around in the footage
summer makes a comment about how someone's always
trying to kill them rick also answers her later
in the trailer someone's always trying to kill
us as some small device burst through the window
looking like it's trying to kill them this is just
the mr nimbus episode with the police showing up
apparently right after he rolls up and jerry
makes that comment about the weird naked man
gyrating around in their lawn rick called
him his nemesis in that comic-con footage
like they crashed in the ocean after this other
scene as if they've had some long-standing feud
that we're just finding out about now but he's
meant to be a parody of marvel's namor and i'm
sure they also make some aquaman jokes too but
it seems like whatever's happening during this
episode it takes them on some underwater adventure
and here's where we get to that evil morty episode
easter egg i've seen a lot of theories about
this mr nimbus episode paying off the rick
lantis mix-up episode from season three so you
remember that the rick lantis mix-up was famously
the bait-and-switch episode that secretly wound
up being the tales from the sizzle episode where
they reveal how evil morty had taken over the
citadel of bricks one of the best episodes of
the series but during the events of that episode
c-137 rick and his morty went on an adventure to
atlantis where apparently morty had a bunch of sex
with mermaids so neymar and the marvel comics also
aquaman at dc both rule over a version of atlantis
so a lot of people saw him show up in this and are
expecting them to maybe reference the events of
that rick lantis mix-up episode at some point
we'll see it would be funny if they make a call
back to that episode this is another scene from
that transformers episode where morty jessica
and rick wind up on a version of cybertron being
attacked by all the transformers lots of beast
wars references in this too with animal themed
transformers it's not clear why the transformers
are abducting morty and jessica though and even
rick here but morty says he screwed it up and
rick's like don't don't feel bad that's what
you do that's your whole thing screwing things
up then makes a reference saying he's going to
deus ex machina everything and normally the series
is actually pretty good about logically explaining
rick's plans for solving whatever the problem of
each episode is so when he says things like deus
ex machina usually he's calling out tropes rather
than the show actually falling into the tropes
that they themselves try to parody then it seems
like there's a whole bunch of thanksgiving jokes
with all the turkeys going on in this episode like
if you remember the terminator episode with time
travel and the planet full of snakes that achieve
higher intelligence so you have armies of snakes
going crazy whatever's happening during this
episode it seems like there's an army of turkeys
and later in the trailer you see rick literally
frying a giant turkey like a kaiju turkey with
one of his weapons it literally starts to crust
over and cook as if they could just turn around
and eat it for dinner later zoom and enhance you
also see suited up with them in this armor suit is
the us president so they're bringing the president
back for this season again this might be connected
to the episode where morty is inadvertently
destroying all the national monuments like
they're inside here looking at a version of the
real constitution morty accidentally fires that
laser right through it then shoots right through
the liberty bell and then the beam just continues
on for some reason it is so hyper accurate that
it destroys the statue of liberty then they have
their big activate voltron scene where they enter
all the lions which rick has apparently hidden
all over the earth they're calling it team gotron
so they don't get sued by toei i assume voltron
the series even though they're parroting voltron
was actually itself an adaptation of toei's
beast king go lion back in the day so if they're
going to get sued by anybody it'd be toe a they
have all that other footage of them fighting the
giant kaiju monster i love the reference that rick
makes to button mashing like they're in some kind
of arcade just press a bunch of buttons we're too
big to fail then later in the trailer you notice
they have that scarface parody rick is fighting an
alternate version of the voltron team it's not
really clear what's going on here but it's meant
to be a big scarface parody say hello to my little
friend as he fires a giant gun shaped like himself
maybe they're just meant to be the real
voltron team or some competing voltron team
the alien that's chasing them here in this scene
is from that same episode with mr nimbus in the
marvel blade reference that we saw in the
other trailers all those alternate reality
shards i believe at the beginning of that episode
they're supposed to be in the middle of escaping
some other monster as if it's the cold open like
showing you the end of some other adventure that
they were on before the actual plot of the episode
picks up this is a weird lego looking inspector
gadget version of rick who has a gun hidden inside
the hollow compartment of his head for some reason
this scene of morty complaining about how dumb
he's gotten having missed so much school i don't
know anything about anything is also from
that transformers episode you can see the
same landscape inside the portal here then
i love this casual dinner scene here where
rick realizes something is wrong because jerry
has gotten a job like that somehow shatters his
reality wait a minute like that's how pathetic
jerry is more footage of that marvel galactus
episode with summer and morty stealing rick's ship
dragging along that tiny version of a solar system
with galactus chasing them down this is just more
footage from the captain planet episode with this
girl version of the character that it seems like
morty really likes in that other trailer footage
more footage of the hellraiser episode i can't
wait to see how they explain the marlin that's
just sticking through rick's body here as if it's
no big deal like of all the craziness here that's
somehow the least interesting thing going on in
this frame then they have a tag scene with them
on some horse-themed planet which i'm sure beth
would love but like i said all the rick and morty
season five episodes are going to overlap with
the marvel loki episodes i'll be doing episode
videos for all that stuff what'll happen is my
rick and morty episodes will post monday mornings
just like they always have in the past marvel loki
episodes are actually going to air on wednesday so
my episode videos for that will post wednesday
mornings but there's going to be a bunch more
trailers for everything coming up there's supposed
to be a new marvel eternals trailer this week
of course i'll do a video for it if they do wind
up releasing it there's also supposed to be a new
spider-man 3 no a home trailer sometime soon in
the marvel what if episodes which is also just
a completely crazy multiverse type of series
those will wind up releasing in august so this
will also kind of overlap with the rick and morty
episodes make sure you have alerts enabled for my
channel so you don't miss any of those everyone
click here for my brand new loki trailer video
and click here for all those other brand new
rick and morty trailers in my episode videos
thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and i'll see you guys tonight!